[Applause]
cardi b living her best life while
hosting a star-studded bash in nyc
following the 2022 met gala oh yes honey
the grammy winner hosted an after party
on monday night with playboy in the boom
boom room at the standard hotel
cardi b i will be at centerfold
doing
exclusives
on tonight's
med gala x playboy party that i will be
hosting it's gonna be fun
i just refresh myself
and i see you there
the [ __ ] rapper who's also playboy's
resident creative director looked fab in
this body hugging black number with gold
embellishments
we're going to be late i gotta teach you
spin king spin that we're gonna make it
kiari's wife
caught you wave mommy
it's what money look like
and she wasn't kidding once she made it
into the party it was lit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah cardi danced on the tables and took
shots with the partygoers and honestly
guys the guest list was like a who's who
of hollywood ready for it
anderson pack i'm gucci from head to toe
dreams can come true don't stop
believing anthony ramos aquafina billy
eilish camila cabello let me see those
nails right oh unbelievable
i love them at gala it's already a win
chloe bailey chloe grace moretz claire
danes cole sprouse is uh the mac is it a
little intimidating
um the first time the first time i did
it i was incredibly nervous i won't lie
to you this would be third time which is
incredible yeah darren chris donatella
versace dove cameron emily ratajkowski
erica badou future jacob ellerty janelle
monae what did you enjoy most about the
process leading up to the carpet
just feeling sensual jared leto justin
thoreau lala anthony lena weith lilly
james lin-manuel miranda maude apatow
miranda kerr normani phoebe bridgers
reggae jean riz ahmed sabrina carpenter
wendy williams and winnie harlow were
there just to name a few
and yes yes i did give that to you in
alphabetical order does anyone have a
glass of water oh snappity snap snap
earlier in the night cardi stunned on
the met carpet rocking this gold versace
number
and when it caught up with winnie harlow
she played coy about where the hot after
party was
where is the after party tonight
wednesday
gotta figure that out
[Music]
you